[Music]
hello and thank you for coming to my
talk I am Sierra Pitman and I a product
specialist at shimazu scientific
instruments and today I'll be talking
about an analytical quality by Design or
aqbd approach to separating cannabinoid
stereo isomers
so what are we going to learn throughout
this talk by the end of this talk we'll
be able to look at the difference in
cannabinoid separation between chyro and
reverse phase stationary phases learn
the benefits of using aqbd principles
for method development and understand
software techniques to help you separate
overlapping
Peaks so where did this all start so
more recently with the decline in CBD
sales many hemp Growers and sellers
began to move towards variants of THC so
this include the big Delta 8 so delta8
is derived from CBD and it has increased
in popularity because it's not specified
as part of the farm bill which we'll get
to in a second and therefore it's not
considered illegal it does not have the
same hucog genic effects as Delta 9 but
it also has some effect and it is
important to be able to accurately
separate each of these analogs
okay so let's talk about the hemp
farming act in 2014 the farm bill
distinguished hemp from marijuana but
the interpretation of this law was vague
and difficult it was not until the hemp
farming Act was signed into the law in
December 2018 that the legalization of
the cultivation and distribution of hemp
was federally legalized now how did they
effect controlled substance Act and the
implications of the Cannabis law being
enforced well marijuana is still
considered a schedule one drug however
it removes a plant Cannabis sativa L
from the CSA as long as the plant
contains no more than 0.3% THC by dried
weight this is very important because as
this was the first time that an actual
value was placed on the psychoactive
compound which forced forensic labs to
adapt to the changes so how did they
adapt well there have been some legal
loopholes so the hemp farming act
specifies Delta 9 THC at 0.3% so has to
be lower Delta H THC is not mentioned in
this bill most legal experts agree that
Delta HC is legal Delta HC and then
later on Delta 10 occur naturally at
minute amounts and then they are not
considered synthetic however Delta HC in
commercial products is synthesized and
unnatural way so how are
scientists analyzing
these so the potency testing is one way
how farmers can make sure that they
don't have more than 0.3% of their of
THC in their crop so before gas
chromatography was actually used for
potency testing however the heated
injection Port can convert all acid
forms of THC to Delta 9 THC due to heat
however this is not always
100% a way that can alleviate this
problem is using high performance liquid
chromatography or hplc and this allows
for full separation of the Native and
acid forms of the THC
isomers so what is hlc well we found out
the hlc is the golden standard potency
testing so hlc uses solvents and has
pull pull through a pump then from the
pump it goes to the injector and this is
where your mobile phase so the solvents
that you pulled then interact with your
sample it then moves through your column
where that is where the separation
occurs and then it can go to your
detector and so with hlc you can use
numerous of detectors but the most
common is usually uvv photo diode aray
or even massp and then after the
detector you have a nice lovely
chromatogram of your separ
compounds so let's take a look at the
naturally occurring cannabinoids so as
you might know the canabo list is
constantly growing so these were the
first um 11 compounds that were of the
most concern so we have Delta 9 THC
Delta 8 THC thca thcv CBD cbda CBN cbdv
CB C BG cbga and
CBC and the ones with the boxes were the
most common and so you see the Delta 9
and Delta ATHC were one of our most
popular and therefore also need the most
separation another one of note is
thcv and this is because it's more
psychotropic than the Delta 9 THC it's
an appetite suppressant and it actually
can occur a very low abundance which can
be detected down to 0.1% of its dry
weight so what does this mean for our
methods so there is a 11 cannabinoid
mixture separation this happens on a
reverse phas chromatography and as you
can see from the chromatogram Delta 9
and Delta HC can be separated as well as
the rest of the
cannabinoids so what happens if we want
to use this in real world
techniques well this can be applied to
many different real world techniques
this is an example of a flower sample
and of an oil sample the black is our
overlay of our standard so that 11 mix
that we just saw and the pink is our
sample so the flour and the oil and as
you can see we were able to detect the
different cannabinoids in both the flour
sample and the oil
sample but as we know the list is
constantly
growing
so to increase the amount of canabo we
can test we added 10 more so this
includes Delta 9
thcp Delta a
thca
cbdp cbco cbcv CBL
thcv cbca cbdv and CB T so what does
this mean for our
chromatogram well taking the same exact
separation that we saw for our 11 we now
have 21 this is also done on a reverse
phase uh system so nothing much has
changed our gradient profile is the same
we're using a UV viz detector the only
thing that has changed is that our
runtime is a little longer to account
for the extended amount of cannabinoids
and if you look at a chromatogram we
still have good separation for all of
the cannabinoids including the Delta 8
and the Delta 9
isomers so to even go further there are
many other isomers that we can look at
these is an example of Delta 8 Delta 9
and I mentioned earlier Delta 10 but
what if we look at different Delta 10
Delta 9 and Delta 8
analoges so if we look at it we see a
lot of different stereo isomers and
chirality in these molecules so what
does that mean for our
chromatography well first let's talk
about chirality so chirality does matter
and the way the molecules interact with
the columns as well as the other um also
matter this is just an example of chyro
compounds and why chirality matters so
if we look at gluc D glucose and L
glucose there's a difference in glucose
as one makes you fat and the other one
has no effect on you as well as the
different medications so ibuprofen the D
is the anti-inflammatory the L does
nothing and as well as the other
medications so chirality does matter and
therefore we do have to separate them
and one of the ways we do this is
through
chromatography
so let's look at the four compounds we
had just mentioned so the Delta 6 a 10 a
THC isomer and the Delta 10 THC isomer
if you look at our chromatogram it
doesn't look as separated as our 11 and
21 mix and we're using the same method
conditions as we did before this is on a
reverse phase stationary phase column
we're using the same gradient and the
same mobile phases
so does this mean can we not separate it
or what should we do next in order to
separate these four
molecules so this can be very
overwhelming of where to start well you
can change the solvents to see if you
can get separation you can change out
your columns and test different columns
until you get your separation and you
can also change your gradients but
that's a lot of things to test one after
the other other so is there a simpler
way to do
this you can use a method scouting
system so with a method scouting system
if we back to our hplc diagram you have
a solvent you have the injection you
have your column and it goes to the
detector well with our method scouted
system it's kind of an expanded version
of this instead of using just two or
four different solvents we can actually
test up to eight different solvents so
you can blend or mix eight different
solvents to see if that can help you
know separate your
compounds okay so we covered the solvent
part what about the columns so instead
of testing just one column at a time we
can actually set up six and even 12
different columns to test with those
different solvents and then it all goes
to the detector to create a
chromatogram okay so when we we go and
we put in all of our columns so we're
using six different chyro pack Cyro
columns and we're only using one organic
and one equ solvent so we're only using
two solvents we actually have an output
of each column has about five different
outputs and so that can be a data
overload which actually makes it very
overwhelming to look at so how can we
make this easier on
ourselves well
with the method scouting in conjunction
with analytical quality by Design or
aqbd principles it actually makes it
easier for the user to screen data
optimize it and actually have a robust
method afterwards and it's all within a
software so what we saw just a slide ago
was our screening phase so this is where
you select all your solvents and your
columns that you think would be suitable
so before we even start with aqbd we
usually like to start with an analytical
Target profile and so we saw that by
using our 21 and our 11 method that
these solvents actually do separate our
cannabinoids so we do have our solvents
and then with our columns we know that
the reverse stationary phase doesn't
work so why not try a chyro column to to
uh separate our chyro isomers so after
the screening phase you're going to have
one good match between a solvent and a
column this software actually allows you
to select your best method so you don't
have to go through all that data sorting
to make sure which method is the best
which column is the best and which solve
is the best the best pair is actually
given to you then you can move to your
optimization phase so your optimization
phase is when we can start testing other
parameters this is like gradients uh
temperatures flow rates even like um how
long you want to hold a certain
duration and then with our optimization
phase again the software allows you to
look at all the different methods that
you tested and select the most optimal
and we will see later on throughout the
presentation it actually has some fun
tools to help you select this such as
predictive chromatograms uh heat mapping
and 3D modeling once you've selected
your ideal conditions through your
optimization phase we go to our
robustness phase and this is just to
make sure that our method is actually
robust and that we can use it to test
all of our other um screening and uh
methods after
this okay so let's start with our four
compound screening phase so we talked
about those four different uh stereo
isomers and that we can't separate it on
the reverse stationary phase so testing
with our six chyro columns we see that
Au U and gu actually have the best
outcome and so if you look at this
compared to the other four ihu was only
able to give us one Peak so everything
came out as one IBU only two and IDU and
ICU weren't able to separate all four
like the I Au U and the
igu now why are we looking at IU and igu
well we're able to separate those four
but let's take a closer look at these
two which is the best if they can both
separate four this comes down to the
retention time so with igu it has a
slightly better separation and a faster
retention time so that is ideal for our
next
step so let's move into our optimization
phase for these four compounds like I I
mentioned before our optimization phase
actually has some fun tools that allows
us to select the best running conditions
so if we see in the middle here we have
our predictive chromatogram so the
software actually predicts that during
these certain running conditions that
you claim that are optimal we see uh
where they're going to elute and if
they're going to
overlap with the heat mapping and the 3D
modeling this actually allows us to
select our optim conditions a little
better so with the heat mapping the red
area is the most ideal conditions
whereas the blue is the least ideal uh
we're able to actually pinpoint with
software the most optimal condition and
then the box that you see is actually
the robustness conditions so this
actually helps us to move to the next
phase of the robustness testing um to
see in what area is our method the most
robust with the 3D modeling we can look
at three different
um conditions so in this case it's
concentration duration of the whole time
um and then this is a minimum resolution
and so the 3D modeling actually gives
you a um visual of where is your top um
most ideal
conditions okay so we went through our
screening optimization and then later we
went through robustness for our
separation of four compound mix and as
you can see we were able to separate our
four compound mix and this was our
method so we used a photo diode array
that way with this system we were able
to scan different um wavelengths and so
221 nanometers was the ideal our mobile
phase conditions was actually um
isocratic rather than the gradient we
saw earlier on um and the separation was
a 40 a to a
60b the ideal column that we saw
throughout our testing of the four was
the Kyro Pac
igu our flow rate was 8 Ms per minute
our runtime was only 15 but as you can
see with our chromatogram here we could
actually reduce it a little bit further
um oven temperature was 40 and the
injection volume was five which that did
not change from the original um 11 and
mix so I keep mentioning the 11 and 21
so now that we have separated our four
very difficult stereoisomer compounds
using chyal separation what would happen
if we added our previous separated 11
mix that we saw on a c18 or reverse
phase um let's see if this causes any
problems separating the four from the
11 Okay so let's start off at the top
from our screening phase the 15
component screening phase as you can see
the igu is the most preferred column
again and in this one we can actually
tell between the igu and the IU that the
igu does provide a better separation as
you can see um the components of this
are a little more separated than that of
the IOU and definitely more separated
than all of the other Cyro columns so
let's take this to the optimization
phase so with our 15 com uh component
optimization and robustness we first
start with our 3D mapping so as you can
see with our 3D mapping we're able to
see a distinct optimal point and so I'm
showing you minimum resolution here um
with the flow rate as well as oven
temperature um with our heat Maps we see
a very narrow down um area that allows
us to choose the most ideal
conditions and then later when we tested
robustness um we see a robustness
statistical output of our flow rate and
our oven temperature that U 1.1 flow
rate and our 45 are optimal conditions
and if we deviate outside of that um
what we can see at our method might get
a little less robust so it's better to
stay within those running
conditions so this is our final
separated 15 compound mix again um the
detector that we use was a photo diode
arade or PDA 221 nanometers isocratic
separation but since we have added a
couple more canabo the separation has
changed a little bit it's it's now a 54a
46b the column stayed the same we
increased our flow rate to 1.1 Ms per
minute um the runtime also increased
since we added 11 more different um
compounds so it is about a 30 minute uh
run time the oven temperature is about
45 and the injection volume stayed the
same at 5
micrometers all right so we talked about
the 11 and original orally we also
talked about the 21 so let's see if we
can also put our four with our 21 to
create a 25 compound
separation so going through that
screening phase originally um we saw the
igu worked for both the four and um our
15 and with the screening phase of this
I didn't want to put all of the graphs
up here to overwhelm you but the igu was
also the best uh to separate the 25
cannaboids this is the optimization of
our 25 canavan noid and as you can see
the evaluation value so the overall best
um running conditions the separated Peak
count and minimum resolution heat maps
are shown here in that square there that
you see under the evaluation value that
is our ideal running conditions and our
uh area of
robustness
so this is the final chromatogram of our
25 compound mix again the detector the
PDA at
221 um an isocratic separation and it
has changed just slightly from our 15
mix we're at a 56a
44b with the same column of the chyro
pack
igu and then we had a slight increase in
our flow rate so 1.3 Ms per minute and
also an increase in our runtime so 50
minutes for this entire separation of 25
compounds the oven temperature was at 38
and the injection volume was still at 5
m
lers so with this um there's more
optimization that can be done we can
play around with gradients a little bit
more to see if we can get a better
separation or even to decrease runtime
but that is a future work um
situation what I do want to point out is
our last learning objective of what if
we can't get everything to separate some
things just may not separate and what if
you want to use just a UV Vis or PDA
versus something um more advanced like a
mass spec well let's take a closer look
at these um colluding or shouldering
Peaks
okay so this is an example of our two
compounds of our 25 mix that are
actually colluding um with Peak
deconvolution we can actually use
multivariate curve resolution
alternating lease squares or to save
your breath MCR ALS and so this is a
math-based um algorithm that actually
allows you to detect co- alluding Peaks
as well as it can be used for impurities
so you can see here that with our Peak D
convolution we're able to tell to tell
where uh one Peak starts and another
Peak ends or the other Peak starts so
our overlapping have actually been
broken down to two different Peaks so if
you are still having problems with you
know separation this is a very handy
tool that can be used to deconvolute
Peaks to see if you know there's just
one Peak with a shoulder if there's a
couple Peaks um or if you even want to
use it for
impurities so finally we've made it
through all of our learning objectives
so
let's to observe the difference in
cannaboid separation between chyal and
reverse phase stationary phases okay so
we saw that THC isomers can be difficult
to separate on just reverse phase
conditions due to their chirality so
kind of alleviating this problem we use
chyro columns and that solve the problem
mostly for co-
alluding our second objective was to
learn benefits of aqbd principles for
method development so aqbd canate the T
task of testing analyzing and comparing
individual runs and we saw this where
you know we're used our method scouting
system to help us um have an I high
throughput uh screening and everything
by analyzing all that data can be
overwhelming but using aqbd principles
as well as assisted software actually
alleviates all that for you and allows
you to have the most optimal run lastly
we briefly saw an understood software
techniques to separate overlapping Peaks
so with Peak
deconvolution Um this can Aid in
identifying cooling Peaks and impurities
of the sample and this can help you look
at um Co alluding as well as the small
little impurities to see if there's one
two or even three or four
Peaks and so I would like to thank you
for joining this talk and if you have
any questions please feel free to reach
out and ask thank
you